where does a fish keep its money in the
river bank this dress costs a hundred
bucks
this phone costs 10,000 bucks we usually
hear people describing money as bucks
right but ever wondered how the slang
for money originated curious time to
find out first of all can you tell me
what buck literally means it usually
refers to a male deer but what does dill
have to do with money for this let's
move back to America of the early 18th
century at that time the US dollar was
not invented and does people trade it in
the form of goods or commodities this
kind of trade is referred to as the bata
system the simplest example would be
exchange of a boat for a bicycle or
exchange of bread for butter and so on
in some parts of America deerskin was
one of the most highly valued commodity
this was usually due to its usefulness
in clothing and Waka sense and also
because of its high quality
therefore trade was usually carried in
the form of deerskin
which was referred to as buckskin people
at that time used to value things in
terms of buckskin for instance 10
kilograms of rice for three buckskin a
pair of moccasins for five bucks skin
and so on one recorded example of this
is where a cask of whiskey was traded by
the European settlers to the Native
Americans in exchange of five buck skins
as time passed buckskin was shortened
took bucks around the Year 1792 u.s.
dollars were introduced which soon
became the main medium of exchange all
the people stopped training in buckskins
the word vos does seem to prevail in the
minds of the people as a reference for
money so this is how the slang
Buc for money originated in the US and
dead spread out worldwide so this was
about the buck the word buck is just a
slang as you know now but every nation
has its own currency for example US has
dollars
Japan has yen India has rupee and so on
on these lines have you ever wondered
why different nations have different
currencies why can't there be a single
currency worldwide are they plans to
build a single currency globally well
this one is your cue box to explore let
us know your findings in the comment
section to be a part of our massive
learning community to subscribe to our
Channel